I think this is a really interesting
topic too for us to be discussing today
I am fortunate enough to be the director
of the UK's oldest purpose-built art
gallery it opened to the public in 1817
and with that comes huge responsibility
and the thing that I try to keep
grounded about is the fact that
ultimately Dulwich picture gallery is
about great art and I like to think
about the way that that art functions
and the power that that art has for
instance we have painting in the picture
gallery which is a portrait of a lady
called Venetia Stanley and she died in
1633
in 1633 her husband lost her a man lost
his wife in 1633 nearly 400 years ago it
happens to us all that we lose somebody
but the man in question was so canal
Digby so canal Digby was a member of
high society of the elite he moved in
circles that meant that he was familiar
with an artist called Anthony Van Dyck
who had come across from Antwerp to
paint the royal family and in this early
1630s he was painting Charles the first
and his family and so when Khanum lost
his wife his first instinct was to call
upon Van Dyck to come and paint her
corpse in bed because that was his way
of coming to terms with his loss now I
think the point you raised Philip about
patronage is so important because Van
Dyck would have never had access the
Canon Digby's grief had kinome himself
not had the wealth to pay for Van Dyck
to come and there is a certain amount of
power and control that comes with a
commission of that type but in my
experience of it once an artist is there
on the scene then they take control no
matter what the limitations of a
commission an artist has the ability
within a certain framework but we all
work within a framework and that is
where correct creativity can flourish
best the artist then takes control of
the situation and can indeed be wrote
about this painting after it had been
finished and said he painted Van Dyck
painted my late wife perfectly he got
every
detail right apart from he added a
flower he added a flower on the bed that
was falling apart that was dying Van
Dyck took that moment in the privilege
of going into an intimate grief ridden
state room and have that ability to go
in and get close to calms late wife and
then to paint her and add in some poetic
license
and there's something that I noticed
when I look at our painting and come to
Dulwich picture gallery see it for
yourselves I will but when you come in
and look at that painting you'll notice
that it's painted it's a very strange
angle because what Van Dyck decided to
do was to paint
mrs. Digby as if he was leaning right
over her and when I look at that and
it's changed in the way I look at it
over over the years when I look at that
I think that actually Van Dyck has
channeled the way that canon would have
leant over her as if he was going to
give her a last kiss and Van Dyck chose
to do that and it is heart-stoppingly
beautiful and means a great deal to me
even more so since I lost somebody
recently my mother the most important
person to me and it means so much to me
that painting so despite the wealth and
the elitism and all of the the trappings
around the creation of this painting
ultimately it's something deeply human
and that for me is a way in for people
to great art the fact that it exists at
all means that we can have a connection
to a human emotion 400 years ago that
can feel as current as if it happened
just yesterday because we can all
understand loss and we can understand
great art and we can understand the
poetry that moment when Van Dyck made
those crucial decisions to create a
painting that has so much power so the
responsibility that I have on my team
have at Dulwich picture gallery is to
try and open that up in various ways to
as many people as possible because then
people can find those connections and
can ultimately find themselves in great
art for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas
i-i-i TV
you